what's going on
reject nation Greg Alva here Andrew here
so today is December 13th still don't
have access to the channel that's
alright though we could just film for
fun
andrew has not seen ex machina so I
thought it'd actually be really
interesting to bring him on here because
we're gonna watch the trailer for
annihilation today annihilation is a
movie from the director of ex machina
I've seen ex machina ex machina is one
of the many of films that I own but have
never watched like Pulp Fiction
Shawshank Redemption just saying Greg
and by the way guys past twenty one
fifty followers on the Stardust app so
thank you guys for following us download
the lingam follows and shout out to
nirvash Krishnan alright ready Andy
let's do it whoa
[Music]
[Music]
and they make a cute couple yes she only
knows how it's no worse characters
[Music]
interesting a lot more story in the trip
[Music]
extremely ill you tell me where he was
what he was doing it was his decision to
go in but nothing comes back looks like
an alien covenant oh not for us it is
like
[Music]
sharks uptake like that not possible you
can't cross great difference be crazy or
something in here kill them something's
come to the
[Music]
we can camp
[Music]
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
that was
did you see the teaser trailer for this
no I didn't the teaser trailer was had a
totally different type of vibe you can
see how they they're it's the same film
man that really threw me for a loop
because I was under the impression this
is gonna be another one of those like
not so much the emotional thrill ride
aspect with horror elements really being
strongly infused I thought it was gonna
be more of you know exploration or
something like that yeah I have a
feeling the marketing is being slightly
deceitful and can I tell you why really
quick sure niall ation which is the
subtitle - my favorite sequel mortal
kombat very ok ok here's what it says
keep in mind I'm reading this from
Wikipedia places ok but under the
release section it says due to a poor
test screening Ellison became concern of
the film is too intellectual and too
complicated and demanded changes to make
it appeal to a wider audience including
making Portman's character more
sympathetic and changing the ending
rudin sided with garland and his desire
to not alter the film defending the film
and refusing to take notes Whedon also
made a final cut of the film there was
this clash of producers but the way the
film was and would like to intellectual
and to complicated it's making you think
too much it wants to buy it more the for
one producer he doesn't think the
audience can handle all this in the end
so what I'm it's making me wonder is is
this trailer doing kind of the arrival
thing where a rival looks like it's
gonna be like thrills and stuff but no
it's really this study and exploration a
sci-fi movie and I have a feeling
anihilation will have a good amount of
that actually and I feel like people
might be a little surprised by that
amount of exploration when they see it
yeah well it's based on a book I haven't
read be interested in that but what I
liked about this trailer in particular
like how suspenseful was you know they
really ramped up but you know some of
the horror elements for me too like I
was genuinely you know just on a trailer
like really feeling the date you know I
really felt like the stake levels felt
really sure and it really feels like you
know when you this group it feels like
we're gonna be infested
the screw please you've got some
talented actresses in this group not
only are you gonna be invested in the
fact that you know they're looking for a
cure for Oscar Isaac because you're
gonna be on edge with that like are they
gonna yeah first of all are they gonna
survive this but are they actually gonna
find that cure in time to you know are
they going to survive so they can find
that cure so I like how they're playing
different elements of the story like
it's not just about survival it's about
you know living so that she can you know
find her husband you know that adds a
lot more weight to the story and a lot
more emotional despotism a personal
motivation here there's there's a fear
there like there was a scary moment
where she was looking at the footage and
like the whole mind crazy they kill each
other something came after them
I want all that the mystery in the
horror vibe I would love it this film
kind of successfully accomplished both
something that I feel like Prometheus
and alien covenant tried doing this film
could probably do it in a successful
manner especially because it's based on
a book that apparently a lot of people
really like grosser would it be a movie
about it I think the biggest thing as a
Star Wars fan especially that I'm gonna
be looking for in this film is hearing
about Oscar Isaac not like saying you
know saying that its course or something
like their chemistry actually looks
really good honestly just from the first
moans like like again I just I know I'm
using this word a lot but I really feel
like just from the little snippets we've
seen in this like that we're really
gonna be emotionally invested in this
couple and like you're gonna want her to
find that curious I think Lou moments
like that just make me like one of the
horror elements and the [ __ ] does go
like crazy that's where I'm like really
on edge and I really want these
characters to survive and refer her to
find something so yeah I mean it looks
very interesting I'm not the biggest fan
of horror stuffs but it's definitely
like the visual the visual imagery
though alone is just it looks incredible
oh yeah know that that all looks
absolutely on par you know and I'm thank
you for pointing that out I feel like
when you watch a trailer you point out
how great the effects are and I feel
like when you watch a movie you hear
more people talk about the parts that
they thought had bad effects so I'm
hoping that this film consistently has
great visual effects as well something
that looks a combination of practical
and CGI like the the whatever that wolf
creature is yeah and even the design of
the alligator with the shark teeth all
of that is all practical and I love
seeing that it feels like a real horror
movie this was like it could be
something special and
I hope it is and also the last thing I
just want to say the cinematography on
this oh yeah it looks fantastic yeah
beautifully shot I mean again I didn't
see ex machina but from everything I've
ever heard anyone say that film is so
gorgeously yes Thompson in the trade
yeah yeah oh I saw her Valkyrie baby
hey we got Valkyrie and Jana yeah argue
over this tooth or love interest man and
you got Apocalypse thank you at all
anyway guys how are you liking the
Annihilation promos are they living up
to your standards
what are your prediction is it gonna
live up to the annihilation name of like
Mortal Kombat annihilation nothing in
the stand top Mortal Kombat annihilation
it's an amazing film so good I love how
they handle Johnny Cage it's just about
say that like just love how the hand
Donnie Cage great just doing then the
first five minutes so smart I remember
thinking I want more Sonya less Johnny
more Jack mechanical shout out today for
Niraj Krishnan
Niraj he's been a longtime follower of
this channel he found us through my
brother's channel the Jia Bao a channel
he has shown I think even more support
for me than he has towards my brother
because Niraj I think you've clearly
stated it I'm the better brother I think
those are your exact words I don't think
I'm making that up in my head I'm pretty
sure you said those words so Niraj thank
you I don't want to cause friction
between you and my brother I just want
to know that if you had to choose a side
to choose me right alright Niraj I don't
want to have to go all Mortal Kombat
annihilation on you don't do it I've
seen a full-circle fatalities subscribe
to the real rejects watch Mortal Kombat
annihilation click that notification
bell if this is up on youtube to your
time
andrew is on the movie source channel on
this channel he has fantastic breakdowns
fantastic reviews this guy clearly knows
film you can tell by the way he speaks
you can be
the patronage act today John John John
we saw the trailer for annihilation
looks fantastic annihilation what is
that I don't know it's my did you watch
it and then do a review on this Stardust
app full circle